I'm Naomi Shah, I'm 16 and I live in Portland, Oregon.
I see science as a means of improving people's lives, of helping,...
...and that's what's really important to me.
I enjoy doing sports.
I swim.
One of the best things about swimming is you see yourself improve over time,...
...and that's one of the things I love.
My heritage is very important, and my family and I are very close.
Both my dad and my brother have year-round allergy symptoms,...
...and I wanted to understand the external factors that were exacerbating it.
I guess that's what inspired my project.
A lot of people don't realize that the air pollutants in their home...
...might have an effect on their lung health.
I've studied indoor air quality and the various ways it affects asthmatic patients.
I was very surprised to find out that many of the factors I studied...
...are not being addressed by air quality regulations.
So I'm hoping to impact policy more directly.
I recently met with Lisa Jackson, the administrator of the EPA,...
...to discuss indoor air quality in our public buildings.
Like schools and hospitals, and I'm planning to do more.
My dream is to become an inventor and entrepreneur,...
...with a passionate focus on environmental public health.
It's hard for one person, especially a student, to make a difference,...
...but I feel like the science fair has given me a platform I never would have had before.
I want to make the world a better place and now I believe I can do it.